I'm looking at you I'm looking at me I'm
looking at you looking at me at you I'm
looking at you looking at me looking at
you I only have one eyeball and you have
a red eyeball God dang
it let's play
broo
Amer let's count how many every time the
people who watch every time uh they say
bro you have they have to take a drink
of lemonade of lemonade yes cuz
oh these dogs what the hell are you
doing to those dogs I'm show them my
Judy
chops oh God damn
that can we hook on this C4 this is all
you need I want to hook on this oh bet
oh [__] oh I flew
back I'm the one oh no I'm throwing
bullets back at
him what the
[__] what did you do K save me save me
sa me there's two of me which one do you
want to be the left or the right the
left pill or the right pill the blue
pill which one is blue
exactly oh yeah that's perfect I want to
be Indiana so I can do
this yeah come over here and give me a
spanking oh
yeah oh yeah Neo
likes oh yeah lady oh [__] oh no save me
again red pill the red pill
bro
ohop oh wait I wasn't RoboCop which do
you hold down you don't hold anything
now you just jump on it oh [__] okay
that's the
problem America God damn it I'm not
American this is from my
friend you messing with me you messing
with all of us oh wait I di now I'm oh
there you are oh there I keep dying Ken
it's not good okay I'm back oh yeah like
the best character ever now
he the
best cuz he can do this what's
up you think you're
fast well you're not Sonic fast god damn
it the
fastest I was about to sing the Sonic
song that's why they did kill you it's
okay I'm checking no oh god really like
I don't
understand that last shot
what make sure he's dead oh God it's a
red one I didn't see it last
time
okay mix this up again all right don't
want to go near the red ones oh no me
too oh I'm
going it was blasted off I was oh I'm
bronan I'm bronan now it's totally
fine okay we have to finish this this is
easy okay okay we can do it wait am I
bronan yeah you're bronan sometimes they
move like crazy and I'm like what the
brand the brarian
no okay we can we can do this it's okay
just run for it just run for it what the
hell are you doing helicopter I hit it
America no oh no I ran over it and it
didn't show up can if you [__] up again
oh I'm dead now oh yeah well what happen
if you go down if you go down you can
save me what are you do
it I can't make it why did you jump why
did you jump you
ass now we got to fail you ass okay now
have a chaina okay what are you at why
where am I what the hell you have to
save me promise to save me
Ken what there's two why am I done why
do I I get to play that's the real
question there you
go you here wait I want to be this one
no hello now we're both black it's
awesome
okay why you keep falling I did not
click I did not click anything I swear
maybe it's maybe it's just the lag and
it's killing me wa okay go to the right
and I should be there you waiting for me
save me
Ken yeah thanks I'm the main character
Rambo or brambo or Rambo I don't
know oh
Jesus oh no I'm not going there got it
oh you can totally just flame
them yes we finally did it the sunet so
happy go go Power
Rangers Love Power Rangers what is
this I think we're going to have to kill
the president that's it
just have a night okay wait why one oh
you were flying in the
air really it's it laging for you was
for just a second it's okay I got
grand grand I have the one ooh B
yes what the [__] is happening I changed
character cuz you saved me even though I
wasn't dead English not dead Sanchez
Sanchez Sanchez
I got you
bro there you go bro welcome bro yeah
anytime bro yeah now SL don't fall off
and die you made it you did it you're
welcome oh he oh you used me as
[Applause]
Shield it's
okay bro I must live on bro tell my w
that I'm not into her don't away bro I
just want Bros yeah bros before
H exact tell my wife bro
before Oh I had a heart attack I guess
and that guy he kicked
me what bro you have to you have to Bro
on bro remember me
bro bro
tears oh you're back bro yeah bro
if anyone is drinking game I'm
cripping you tripping bro oh bro
tripping America bro America Freedom bro
oh I'm hugging you right now bro oh yeah
I'm rock hard you see my that's not my
sword you painted silver just for me
just for you bro you know I love it
silver bro it's a true Bromance oh bro
bro can't believe you did that for me
bro yeah bro unlocked Boondock Bros yay
oh oh bro I'll make a path bro thanks
bro I'm going to fly away bro see you
later oh oh it's just you you have to
Bro on where's my
bro where is he wait there has to be a
way to get up here
okay for my
bro I inan brev bro Haven bro Heaven no
Brevin was good brev what Happ oh [__]
he explode
bro I think I'm a girl I think I had
boobs did you I saw pixel boobs I swear
I didn't see your boobs what is this oh
you're the
one oh yeah change Oh My Bullets went
flying different ways
no it's okay yeah bro bro meet me on the
save what bro meet me on the sa bro yeah
bro br br Bruh Bruh BR bro bro bro BR
not cool bro oh I'm here bro bro you
still alive bro bro I'm alive bro bro
I'm alive BR I never doubt you for a
second bro I got come down there so
second can freaking see where you're
going BR safe oh bro I'm going here bro
bro bro bro bro bro you want a turkey
bro I B it just for
you how did you not love turkeys bro
this is like an alligator and some
cigarettes ah shot I'd buy that okay
throw the chicken and ask him what's for
dinner I fail bro do it again you have
to just do it oh wait okay I'll
find did it what do you want from me I
don't have any special I was going to do
it if you're a bro you have to do a
silly one liners I I had one and God
damn it next one no
bro it had to be not cool bro I had to
go on bro I'm I'm sorry but like bro you
didn't jump bro bro you totally bro
cocked me wait bro blocked
me bro cocked me you broed me
bro wait watch this
bro
[Music]
bro more
bro that too cool bro bro they're like a
remote control hey bro
BR bro that chick is
brewing that chick is brewing it
up she's a total bro she's a total bro
she's wearing a a bra yeah bro get it
bruh yeah yeah bro best pun for today
that was terrible
even so funny yeah lift off oh yeah yeah
bro oh good job bro yeah I'm so turned
on right now bro oh God I see you lay on
the spikes it gets me
hot don't worry it's a flesh wood I'll
stay you down here where am I supposed
to go go down I guess um yeah bro oh bro
if you come back to me bro tell me how
do I
freaking I would go up and
then how how do I get over there I don't
know bro you find a way
soon yeah bro BR we need it's not fun
anymore we're pushing it so hard this is
hard not no this [__] that's so
[__] [__] well at least you have
that now do you even know where to go
bro I have no idea bro do you even live
no okay thanks so where do we go yeah
let's just go down I guess oh it's not
fun without saying
bro okay just keep going it's the
American flag bro why is it not a
Swedish flag bro I thought you were a
total bro like why oh you died bro I
died for you bro you thanks
bro I know I couldn't I couldn't go on
alone exactly anytime bro
okay
okay uh it's just you you have to save
someone but I'm down there just go
down you kind of look like a squirrel
you kind of it can't I don't know if
that's
racist oh I on a
grenade thank you
[Music]
Bravo shut
up okay oh [__] oh what it just blew up
what happened okay i j landed on him no
okay what you want to do it's really
good wait click why is it
lagging what the freak oh was lagging
like crazy for me hey you're there
you're up there yeah I don't know what
happened it froze all whatever oh okay I
thought you want here yeah bro broo the
bro out no I'm Keo dude yeah
dude I don't remember how blad speaks
like I hate
vampires okay okay here here here watch
this okay now wait what's for
dinner death oh God damn
[Music]
it I guess it to me to son of a [__]
wow you must be so
impressed death yes yes it was oh no
help me you just hold left you'll make
it I don't you oh [__] you're right so
lucky
yeah so broy okay that was so
broken no oh [__] that almost hit
me I was broken and alone until I find
my bro we BR it up and played some Hello
Bro oh oh oh oh do you even play Hello
Bro hello bro do you even play hello
bro bro do you even play COD
bro 360 Snipes do you even do 360
bro yes got this body oh I found a
body
Minecraft we should build a house how do
you go can you make this go down this
way
bro what do
we I got you bro how do this work I got
you
bro just we just go around I'm not sure
that was how you're supposed to do it
but you know it worked it worked indeed
just as my Sanchez my mustache gets me
cussy just kidding I just want
BR Sanchez they got me they got you they
got me Sanchez I'll shave my mustache
for you oh you there you go you're
welcome you got to you got to touch me
touch me Sanchez yeah you like that
oh totally blew me up all right it's
just you I got this chainsaw man
no that sucks I'm not going to [__] this
up okay there you
are what the hell just happen there's my
old
body I could have just done that but you
know yeah all right okay all right
there's something up here I wanted to do
okay wait I want to change some of this
guy watch this
uh God damn it I was thinking of a pun
but
whatever try hard me just hold down this
to okay ride the porcel pony okay so
these are elevators but I don't know how
to activate them down
up why oh oh oh okay cool oh the Mecha
bro bro watch out for the
oh you cut my hair
bro don't worry I'll come up for you bro
all right bro no wait what the [__] did
you say to me bro whatever bro oh my God
there's
like you can do it bro yeah
brome
Broome whatever oh did we do it yeah
that was it we did
it I guess how do I explode
there I'm going to explode on you babe
oh yeah
bro back in the jungle we're back in the
jungle a that's a little disappointing I
wanted to murder the
president that would have made sense in
this game I don't know why murder the
president yeah Bros don't murder the
president oh I can charge my sword bro A
Sanchez oh oh oh don't look at me too
much sunlight bro you know how sensitive
I am to sunlight bro you got to use some
SP bro 80 bro you got to put some suntan
screen on me bro all all right bro put
it on my back oh thanks bro you're a
real bro man yeah I'm up I'm up God dang
it B bro bro
oh bro oh they don't hit you you're so
lucky Sanchez is not scared of nothing
look at the the right the picture in the
right corner or left corner like
yeah all right here we go you
can
whoa it must be the mustache it must be
see you
later oh I cannot believe you did
that that was pretty good I never let
you down bro oh oh bro you almost let me
down what the hell bring
bro I'm hanging over the edge bro take
my hand bro help me bro it's okay you
made it
bro oops what is that it's a fart
oh oh it's Air Force I didn't know that
I call it an air
strike cuz you're checking Aries cuz I'm
checking
Aries
Jesus oh god oh chain I'm not Sanchez
anymore what was
your for
dinner do
it
death
oh Jack no is down what happened you
just went fly off the screen I flew on
the rocket I went on top of
it come on I got to see my BR out
bro watch out
bro oh thanks man oh yeah you got the
the Bro
brator totes got the
broos Totes My Goats watch out
bro he don't care is what
the happened you can you can sa me yeah
bro thanks all these guys just jumping
at his thing confused what oh want
one ooh bad if they shoot bullets they
like go back at them oh
cool that makes
sense Jesus Christ
br
br God damn it I was distracted by the
Mecha and then I saw at the last second
son of a
[__]
came from the heart so devastated you
left oh okay this this is different I
guess not really they just you have an
extra bro bro let me call my third bro
bro I got totally got smashed bro oh bro
don't worry I'm going to not save you I
guess because I can't no bro just shoot
them bro oh go oh bro you
totally you weren't even born yet bro BR
that's like an
aboian
sh that was pretty weak it's the
president I think all of them are weak
it's okay okay just Thro it up it is the
President we get
St keeps happening bro dead okay I'll
just stop time
okay you did
it too late oh you can totally make him
go down there oh oh God yeah it's
awesome let keep shooting bombs there
and you're you're done for oh
dang we could have made it why did you
have to
die that just stood there would hit me
you n oh no I'm the
woman is that the woman like going to
get Fly cuz I said that I don't know
that might
be oh what what oh you're Broc cop so
it's okay charging targeting
Target him Target Found You Did It Must
Destroy got him I got
him targeting targeting targeting where
is
he what the hell bro bro you got to Bro
man bro Norris okay let let me use my oh
[__] I'm
dead oh sh thanks bro
oh not toally lame bro that was totally
not
broish
no hey chicken man I'm not going to do
it again but
yeah
so did those plant growing him from
being along he's even got skulls in the
front that guy's a bad bad man that guy
is a terrible man Terri killed many Bros
oh God God I thought I was going to be
safe in that hole that was wrong bro
Sanchez bro Sanchez no prisoners what
for dinner
death it didn't
work yeah yeah yeah bro Sanchez America
America you're not leaving me oh y I'm
in the screen I'm in the screen I'm
famous look
Mom
only you
died it's the only thing that's not stop
bro L fling our our bro copter brocker
our
broter BR bro I need sent screen Bruh
Bruh BR my back please bruh all my chest
too I the one the one bro you know I
don't worry bro come here bro I got you
my shest get really bad man you got
to all right slow slower got to work out
those Kinks you're so
tense my now my butt cheeks all right
stand up
here I can't do bro oh the coconut is
crazy it's knocking me out bro I think I
don't see you that way
bro I just got shot in the face
bro don't worry I am the law ah
I forgot what his punch line was or
whatever
okay I got
you God bro what did you do
done well you're the true bro now I know
bro I've always been the true bro that's
why I go to space Oh [__] I missed ah no
space for you bro space and time and
Bros that's how the universe was
made universe is made like that SP bro
that's bro that's
deep that's not very brisan I got
D you don't believe in the one two
breezes bre oh brewi is that's not very
brewi
Bru good one God dang it I saved it for
a long time
actually saving that joke in case it
came
up it's like one of those jokes you
think of when you're like laying in bed
trying to go to sleep you're like my
God all right better call in the Bro
Force oh that's the title of the game
[__] BR
[Applause]
Force hey you ruin my oh this rain bro
it's too rainy getting my hair wet
bro bro I told you to wear a sun head
bro hat but it's
raining I need a br Brella
oh God it's
terrible the puns are so
bad um I guess okay here we
go bro epic
bro bro I think we should end it here
with a epic
bro F an epic oh God fist me bro fing
you right now bro oh bro I'm fisting you
so [__] hard bro godamn it kind of
hurts bro
sorry okay I I I can't play more this is
too this is too
much
okay that was fun pro day every day